fox news alert breaking in washington
tonight where our capitol hill
correspondent chad pergram tells us he's
been hearing whispers suggesting there
could be some new high-profile
confirmation hearings on the horizon in
the house of representatives why is this
a big deal because the house does not
confirm normal nominees but it does
confirm vice presidential nominees does
this have something to do with kamala
harris it's no secret she's been running
out of favor with the biden team over
the weekend someone at the white house
leaked several stories criticizing
kamala for her constant gaffes and
awkward laugh the vice president's
office responded to those leaks by
leaking a story of its own calling the
biden team racist
chad pergram joins me now chad so what
exactly are you hearing
good evening jesse well there's a lot of
conjecture right now about the future of
vice president harris and her lagging
poll numbers this happened at the white
house yesterday during the ceremony to
sign the infrastructure bill
please welcome heather kurtenbach
in a moment
[Laughter]
the faux pas was probably not
intentional but it underscored issues
some have in the biden administration
with harris now here's a window into my
world as you know i appreciate
congressional process and mechanics so i
got a message recently from someone who
knows capitol hill very well and they
suggested i should familiarize myself
with the process to confirm a vacancy
for the vice president in the senate and
in the house to be clear to be clear
this is not something to say that
something is afoot here but i always do
my homework especially about process
vice president nelson rockefeller who
served under president ford was the last
vice president confirmed by congress the
senate and house must confirm a vice
president jesse
very interesting and we'll definitely
stay on top of that that could be big
news if it's headed in that direction
thank you so much chad
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilny and i'm
ainsley earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis